we need a new president because I don't
think Joe Biden seems awfully worried
that the dollar is no longer becoming
the world Reserve currency you can say
that it wasn't a good idea for us to
become the world Reserve currency
however it's a fact that if we stop
being the world Reserve currency every
single person in America gets
significantly poor overnight the fact
that people have to turn their goods and
services into dollars is kind of a
stimulus boost just baked into our
economy we're we're kind of a we're a
place of Last Resort a refuge if you
will it's a built-in advantage that we
don't even recognize or realize till we
travel the world but I think we have
more staying power than people realize
there's a lot of entrepreneurs we create
a lot of value in this country and some
very valuable companies despite the fact
that we're service based we still have a
lot of Natural Resources we have a
manufacturing Beast that can still be
Unleashed if necessary so we have a lot
of advantages with that being said
though this current Administration seems
unbothered by any of this